this video is sponsored by Shadow verse
shadow verse is a free-to-play anime
card game or pc and mobile they can
build competent decks in for absolutely
free I mean just completing the tutorial
alone gives you 50 free card packs form
your strategy around different leader
classes you can pick from and take it
from me I am a tactical genius so I
built my deck around which class had the
best-looking waifu yes I am a genius I
am a patchy that was my mistake I didn't
pick the 500 year old lolly it has a
campaign mode that is fully voiced in
Japanese in English and right now they
are even doing a fete collaboration
yes fate leader skins based on the
heavens feel movie are now available to
buy until February the 27th don't ask me
where this fits in fate law sign ups
also open for the shadow vers open where
winners received $4,000 a free pack for
every match won and a chance to compete
in the million dollar Grand Prix in
Tokyo click the link below to download
it on Steam or you can also find it on
iOS and Android and with that said let's
get on with the video remember when I
said that 2017 was a pretty ok year for
anime well 2018 muscle heard that and
was like ok watch this
[Applause]
Devilman cry-baby there were so many
shows worth watching that there wasn't
even enough time to watch everything
worth watching so I'm not even gonna
pretend to say that I as one man can
accurately say what the best parts of
anime in 2018 was because I guarantee
but there was something that I missed
however with such a massive year I
wouldn't want to miss the chance to talk
about some of my favorite things I know
last year made this video because of the
anime Awards but I'm not gonna be
involved this year so I'm just doing
this completely for myself because it
basically gives me an excuse to talk
about everything I had to cut in my 2018
year review there's no official
structure on following I'm just gonna
talk about [ __ ] I liked so let's do this
[ __ ] every other category was skipping
rights the big one and 2018 was
heartbreaking because there were only so
many hip hats I could give cuz you're a
good girl and you're a good girl and
you're a good girl and not not you get
the [ __ ] out of it I'm Z reach thoughts
levels we had previously thought
impossible best girl in Zombieland saga
was made of relevant cuz the manager man
shall outshine them all his story is
character actions literally made me
stand up and Cheer in the scene where
she finally told Aaron to shut up and
get over it already once my trigger but
man do they know how to make their
[ __ ] girls 0 to dominated her show so
heavily that even after the two-thirds
marketing series when I carried her went
[Music]
somehow someway the nearest competition
was still nowhere near close
then grid man came along has started the
Holy Church of Rica's thighs only for
the faith to be fractured when the
sacred temple of arkanese feet was
founded
I became a religious man this year let's
be real buddy girls Empire could have
essentially run a best goal of the Year
competition against itself and nobody
would complain of which my would still
clearly be the winner but despite my
being by far my favorite girl of the
year I still have to give a shout out to
me key from devil man crybaby who has to
win by default because she was clearly
head and shoulders above the rest
I'm going to hell I feel with the amount
of quality we have this year I would be
doing a disservice to many great shows
that got largely overlooked for one
reason or another in other words the
ones that weren't simulcast by Netflix
that were just on Amazon Prime in the
Netflix corner you had dragon pilot and
high score girl dragon pilot is right up
there with hina matsuri is one of the
most uplifting anime of the year in this
weird slice of life where dragons can
transform into fighter jets after
swallowing a human and that sounds like
war and it is kind of war but it's like
wholesome for
let's just immediately forget I just
said that like an highschool girl was a
key romantic comedy set in the backdrop
of 90s gaming this was an amazing love
letter to old school arcades with
real-life games and consoles that
existed if you have any interest in
retro gaming you will absolutely love
this but to me the biggest overlooked
anime of the year was bananafish this
was swept under the carpet thanks to
Amazon Prime and the strong home
eroticism on display at the beginning
but despite the blatant man service
bananafish is not a yaoi
instead it's an intense dark crime
thriller that tackles very adult themes
including sex trafficking drug abuse
former rape PTSD with a very human
relationship right at the center if you
come in expecting a show about two boys
breaking each other in bed you're gonna
be sorely disappointed because the only
one who gets broken is probably gonna be
you by the end of it I just want us to
be happy yep this one's gonna be a
biggie I'm splitting this up into two
parts my favorite fight scene on my
favorite active series as all the best
fight scenes this year came from
continuing franchises and boy did we get
some [ __ ] amazing fights this year
here acha of course returned for the
Battle of the oles that in terms of
narrative weight was my moment of the
year even if the fighter self did just
boil down to one orgasmic punch black
balls versus better did the impossible
and made me cheer the sight of a stir
screaming at the top of his lungs attack
on titan had some absolutely godly cuts
that made me question if I ever won this
series to go back to being about
fighting Titans I mean screw fighting
giant naked people when we can just
watch Levi enter a bar in the most extra
way possible
it's a Friday and I won my [ __ ] beer
Goku vs. Jaron was hyping up romesco
actually advertised it like a
professional boxing match that was
publicly broadcasted even if it wasn't
technically League or making it the only
fight in 2018 that people illegally
streamed for free and wasn't
disappointed enough in to still ask for
their money back but man I would have a
hard time picking anything but Naruto
and Sasuke vs. Moe mashiki the best
Naruto fights continue to blow my
goddamn mind with the framing tempo and
technique of old-school Hong Kong kung
fu movies mixed in with anime
superpowers I mean just look at this
[Music]
anyone remotely familiar can recognize
Moe mashiki using Wing Chun in his
hand-to-hand scuffles this fight is
literally hip man with [ __ ]
superpowers how awesome is that
but what I also love is that it still
contains the same tactical dev without
stopping to explain everything that
happens and just letting it play out in
real time which was damn exhilarating I
mean Naruto and Sasuke even reused the
same shuriken shadow clone strat they
used the skids litoris just for its
choreography Direction execution and
just pure orgasmic spectacle this was my
fight of the year in terms of pure
action shows though there wasn't
actually that many to pick from this
year sword art online alternative was
just a celebration of everything not
sword art online I mean it was so not
sword art online for this straight-up
told you that this was not sword art
online from the first two episodes of
mega lo box I was essentially expecting
Hajime no bebop with a pure unfiltered
hai fest but instead it became something
more like a ping pong the animation
esque introspective character study that
explores the themes of desire and
ambition it was really good just not in
the way I expected and as a side note I
still can't get over the fact that they
purposely scaled it down to 480 feet to
give it a 90s aesthetic
which I get but I just want to
experience this in the best quality it
can be I mean why stop there why not
give me the choice to experience this in
the authentic mid-2000s aesthetic
[Music]
oh yeah
so because of that to me there was one
clear winner for action show of the year
every year that comes along one show
that makes me think I'm actually a 5
year old kid trapped in an adult body
and holy hell grid man was it this year
this made me feel like I was watching
such late morning cartoons again as a
kid yet somehow going in a direction
that genuinely surprised me it's got
giant monsters it's got robots combining
it's got people shouting of tag names
and it's got CG that I actually liked if
you grew up a fan of Power Rangers or if
you're like me and you grew up too badly
tied up episodes of Ultraman whatever
state line your grandma's house in Asia
you will have an absolutely blast with
this show it strikes the perfect balance
of childish nostalgia with adult themes
done in a way anyone can enjoy thank you
trigger for saving anime once again from
yourselves look we all know I'm not the
opie guy but even I can appreciate a
good Opie when I see one
Jojo is back as stylish as ever with a
James bond-esque opening and yet somehow
got out styled in the same season by a
freaking idol show and hold on yes
that's the sound of every Jojo fan
getting ready to crucify me pop team
epoch was an awesome meme filled frenzy
you had a team you know say which is the
only lyrics to that song and you can't
convince me otherwise
persona fives opening was pretty much
the only good thing by the adaptation
which I can also say about kukuku which
had an absolute banger of a song that I
listened to countless times even if I
never got past the second episode but in
my mind there was one o.p that really
stood out to me above all others
something that completely blew my mind
and that was my discovery of watching
anime on Netflix and having a skip o P
button
my favorite AP of 2018 I just really
liked endeavor man cry-baby how in his
edu just let you skip to the next
episode
holy [ __ ] best OST was a hard one this
year because there were so many great
contenders the pillows were back with
their a-game it's really really
progressive an alternative which turned
out to be pretty much the only thing I
liked about the new seasons a place
further than the universe mastered the
art of the Anna Hana [ __ ] cry technique
that has now conditioned me to bawl my
eyes out on command at the mir signal of
using any of its insert songs but
overall there were three vastly
different OS T's that were a close
contender for the top spot violet ever
garden was far and beyond the most
beautiful soundtrack this year which is
only fitting for the most beautiful
looking show this year
this OST takes you on this dazzling
beautiful journey and manages to
communicate emotions more succinctly
than violet is able to do for most of
this show considering the show was about
learning to express yourself and coming
to terms with your feelings the track
said more than a lot of the dialogue
ever needed to and then to completely
switch gears Devilman crybabies use of
since we've gave the show one of the
most unique sounds I've heard in anime
giving it this retro futuristic feel
that was pretty much perfect for masaaki
yuasa z' mind-blowing vision it is a
psychedelic ecstasy fueled acid trip and
i [ __ ] love it however by a thin
margin I think there was one score that
just beats both of them out
megalo boxes OST immediately stood out
to something special the hip-hop
inspired sound was perfect for the
gritty urban street life and joe's
journey from grimy underground to
superstardom you know you're listening
to a special OST where every episode
brings in a new track when you end up
hunting it down and putting it on your
phone so you can listen to it on endless
repeats and megalo box was no
exaggeration just that the whole
soundtrack is so incredibly stacked
whether you just want something to cheer
to something sad or something that makes
you feel so invincible that you're hyped
up to get in a ring and kick some
[ __ ] ass
No
alright time for some quickfire
categories about shows I've recently
talked about so I don't want to repeat
myself there slice-of-life
come the anime best adventure a place
that's actually within this universe
best animation viola ever garden and it
wasn't even close
best Thriller devil baby cry man best
fantasy that time ago reincarnated as a
slimy boy and tried to make friends with
everyone before becoming Hokage over
hidden leaf village is this title long
enough yeah I really want this for your
light novel best drama or romance well
the best couple of this year is clearly
suck turd my I feel bloomin to you as a
better romance show that explores teen
love better but bunny grill senpai still
remains my drama of this year and that
leads us to the biggie ping you in the
city oh that's right best anime of 2018
just kidding guys pingu only gots a
cameo in this one cuz it's a place
further than the universe I don't need
to say any more about this I've already
talked plenty but in a year of amazing
anime to me this one stood out as the
most special but let's be honest this
year it was in no way clean-cut or will
be unanimous among us so I do have one
final thing to say before we truly hang
up our coats and say goodbye to
everything that happened in 2018 for
real I wanted to take some time for
serious reflection on the year gone by
the general consensus for 2018 was that
it was an amazing year for anime and
personally I absolutely agree it has
been a very long time since I've seen a
year with this many good shows in it
with as much variety as a hat action
romance slice of life fantasy maui idols
q girls mecha sports comedy there was
something for everyone this year that
i'm sure any person can find several
shows they'd enjoy even if they could be
some me show that wasn't really talked
about there's been a huge abundance of
anime for a few years now but 2018
didn't just have more shows than people
could keep up with it had more good
shows than people could keep up with and
the scariest thing is that looking at
2019 that doesn't seem to be slowing
down at all the first impressions of
this winter season is that it's really
[ __ ] strong with a mix of small and
large franchises in a variety of genres
like [ __ ] is this the final form of
anime we were hoping to reach 5 10 20
years ago when we wondered what if anime
actually became popular like what if
there was enough interest in this medium
that there would be more shows worth
watching than we could realistically
keep up with and that's kind of happened
this year hasn't it yet despite all this
something seems to be missing doesn't it
to me
2018 was the year of countless great
shows and Xero classics once again there
wasn't a show that lit up the community
you've really left its mark on the year
will be something that will look back on
and say yes that was the show or shows
that defined 2018 well I think pound for
pound there were just as many shows
worth watching if not more so with more
variation than the last legendary years
of anime of 2011 2006 and 7 it just
doesn't feel a special and I'm not sure
if that's just me nah statically looking
back or because it's just what anime has
evolved into those were the years where
the show's defined that generation of
anime fans Death Note Code Geass curing
the garden Madoka Stein's gates but
today anime is no longer that same
uniform medium as I've said before being
an anime fan doesn't hold the same
weight as it used to because you can
have for people that are anime fans that
watch completely different stuff and the
anime shows themselves have become this
sort of shorts hard-hitting commodity
that we consume enjoy then move on from
it makes me wonder if we'll ever see a
classic again as I look back on this
past year I don't have a standardized
list of top anime I would recommend from
the year but instead just a very healthy
choice of shows for whatever taste mood
or niche that you want you don't have to
look too hard to find a show you'll
enjoy but I feel because of that it
lacks the same cohesion and identity
because despite how many great shows
there are despite the sheer volume of
choice we have to pick from and the
variety of everything available by the
end of 2019 we would have forgotten
about 90% of them and that's what I
think I'll remember 2018 for it's the
year I noticed anime was nowhere near
the uniform landscape it was it's the
year we got more great choice than ever
from the result of the heavier
commercialization that has come with its
popularity it's the year I feel the
landscape matured to a point that it
became more reminiscent to other
mainstream entertainment industries
rather than the niche fandom it used to
be but of course anime still growing and
it's still growing very fast so who
knows what 2019 will have in store for
us
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much again to shadow us
for sponsoring this video if you want to
check out their game click on the link
in the description below to download it
on Steam and also thank you very much to
Joseph Warren Selim sayin Nicholas Tatum
Mike elfin sisters one zero zero eight
six hella fall and everyone else my
patron Phelps for me this month oh I'm
back from my holiday which was meant to
be my Christmas holiday but not really a
Christmas holiday I know you're probably
expecting a winter season video but I
just needed a break from seasonal anime
for a bit and I gave you time to catch
up on some stuff I missed last year so
that's why I wanted to make this video
because I couldn't mention everything in
my anime in 2008 EU review but hey I
wouldn't be giga if I didn't make at
least one late 2018 video right the
winter video will be coming soon there's
I'm back in full force so until then
I've been doc and I'll see you all next
time